it's hard to imagine being on the wrong
end of such extreme engineering but this
tiny video camera brings us up close and
personal a camera worn by one of those
rare humans skilled enough and brave
enough to wrestle a grizzly bear
in this corner at five foot eleven and
220 pounds Homo sapiens
aka Troy hi a professional animal
trainer
46 and 550 pounds
aka Adam the grizzly bear
hundreds of times
and for fun
inhale again rings the rest of us as
closest week I asked to feel his pain
oh boy yeah what that feels like when he
puts his weight on you crushes you could
feel your vertebrae is crack and he's
just playing with a bear that nearly
killed Lily Vancouver wasn't fun
is a grizzly when every
in Montana a simple test may reveal the
answer at the grizzly and wolf Discovery
Center outside Yellowstone National Park
engineering professor Doug Cairns and
student Jason intuitive are set to
calculate their power all they need are
some very heavy objects and cooperative
bears but bears don't move large objects
just to prove they can they need a much
tastier reward
I've got peanut butter and dry dog food
that's coated with maple syrup it works
like a charm a thousand pound grizzly
named Sam
dumpster end-over-end lifting the 675
pound wrong only one